la majorité silencieuse contre la foule
bruyante depuis des temps immémoriaux
les dirigeants s'en sont prévalus dans
les périodes de turbulences où laure
autorités étaient remises en question la
macro ni elle a trouvé une variante aux
concepts opposés la majorité silencieuse
vacciner aux manifestants contre le
passage du ter plus ou moins réduit un
statut d'anti vax grincheuse est opposée
à la science un peu comme si le fait de
se faire injecter un vaccin revenait à
voter oui à un référendum sur la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement dès
le départ des manifestations le pouvoir
a mis en place sa stratégie de
communication consistant à
systématiquement minimiser l'ampleur du
mouvement comparé aux millions de
français vaccinés les chiffres de
mobilisation à retenir aujourd'hui ce
sont près de 45 millions de français qui
ont reçu au moins une injection et les
37 millions de français désormais
protégés cette mobilisation la sauve des
vies par ailleurs l'apparition de
pancartes ouvertement antisémite brandie
par des militants d'extrême droite
présents dans certains cortèges ou des
références à l'occupation et au nazisme
ont soulevé de forte indignation dans
l'opinion publique vous avez deux cent
mille personnes qui ont manifesté à
samedi pour dire qu'il voulait pas du du
vaccin avec dédé des pancartes
extrêmement bariolés et des motifs
parfois extrêmement douteux
permettez-moi de le dire voire
complètement complètement crade sépaq à
tout le monde mais on en a vu beaucoup
moi je pense que le gouvernement
comprend que ce mouvement n'est pas
caricatural mais il essaye de le
caricaturer si vous regardez dans les
manifestations le profil des gens
vous n'avez pas des fous vous avez des
gens du quotidien quoi donc c'est pour
ça qu'on veut à tout prix et caricaturer
ce moment moi je pense très sincèrement
que ce mouvement c'est parce qu'il est
difficilement caricatural qu'on essaye
d'en faire des tonnes sur encore une
fois si cette affaire de pancartes par
exemple à la rentrée on va avoir la
rentrée sociale on va voir également la
vaccination des plus jeunes
donc tous à conjuguer la sphère que vous
allez avoir énormément de gens dans la
rue et c'est ça ce qu'ils craignent
pendant le mouvement des gilet jaune qui
est souvent comparé à celui contre le
pass sanitaires la radicalité et la
violence de certains manifestants
avaient largement été exploité par
l'exécutif que certains prennent pour
prétexte de parler au nom du peuple et
n'étant en fait que les porte-voix d'une
foule haineuse s'en prennent aux élus
aux forces de l'ordre aux journalistes
aux juifs aux étrangers aux homosexuels
c'est tout simplement la négation de la
france samedi dernier il ya eu selon les
chiffres très contestée du ministère de
l'intérieur moins de manifestants dans
les rues pour la première fois depuis le
début du mouvement contre le pass
sanitaires et le chiffre est encore très
important pour une veille de 15 août et
dans les rues le slogan principal reste
liberté une revendication qui peut
toucher un public nettement plus large
que les antilles vague sur les radicaux
de tous bords et ce public malgré le
mépris du gouvernement pourrait bien
devenir de plus en plus urticants alors
que la course à la présidentielle
commence à poindre à l'horizon